prism is one way I would say another one
what you're saying is you're gonna
determine what is the truth it's not
because somebody says it's the truth
we have to find out whether it is true
let me finish my ways right so I said
that you can either do it in two you can
either Intuit it so in other words it
can be something in two intuitive like
the existence of man it can either be
something which is logically reasoned
like for example from first principles
and I would put underneath that or next
to it mathematics mathematical truth
okay right so I would say mathematical
truths are also something which are
which can be proven if you put things
together one way or another regardless
of the category yeah yeah you're finding
there are ways to find out that is true
right and I would argue that you can do
that the important point there yes is
that you don't call it truth if you
can't show that it's true absolutely
would it be dishonest yes to claim
something yes not yes so that's where I
draw the line I may believe something
very strongly but I won't say it's the
truth unless I can show that it's true
right because I think it's dishonest to
do it I'll be honest with you our in ice
I believe that our conception because I
know that you might so I apologize
because I'm dead all right sorry I
apologize no I understand that you might
have good enough to go wait yeah well
we'll make this very quick so I
understand our own that you might have
encountered a lot of Christian
fundamentalists and things like that
I want to say from an Islamic
perspective our conception of God I love
that you've gotten your a t-shirt right
it's completely different from that of
the Christian God right in that it's not
triune it's not Jesus being you know God
or the Son of God so what I would say is
that bearing that in mind and bearing in
mind that our understanding of God is an
incorporeal immaterial one necessary
being which is independent I would say
that that can be proved from first
principles Aaron and I can prove that to
you right now you've improved yeah yeah
from first principles and I'm not saying
God exists in the vernacular
once again thinking about okay
eminent philosophers who are atheist how
is that possible now it's possible that
people can believe in false beliefs
right yeah just because I just because
people are believing people I'm talking
to a novel yeah yeah Wow anyone can make
a claim boy you have to ask the same way
I want to invite you to something yeah I
do a semi-regular video series where I
read a few servers of the Quran right I
write a blog post my impression of them
I'm only a third of the way into the
bank right and then I have a video
hangout with a number of mostly expose
once I have one believe and they correct
me on what I got once I don't know
anything about the hip Iran all right no
problems as much as I can
yes no I'm happy to I'm happy to assist
with that all right yeah and I'll give
you my number before you leave but I'm
about to leave no no just this I want to
say one one thing and then you can kind
of challenge it if you want what was
going to say is you agree that there are
contingent things in existence things
that depend upon other things for their
existence and things which could be
arranged in any other way for example
right you're wearing a t-shirt the
t-shirt that you're wearing has is that
it depends on some kind of material and
it could be rearranged in any other it
could be blue it could have been green
or yellow right so those things are in
existence contingent things possible
things are in existence yes if it's
possible and now here's my here's my
here's my poster has my postulation my
only postulation today my postulation is
that it's impossible for there to be a
world where there are only possible
things in existence and I'll tell you
why how I reason that I reason that I
reason that we can talk about well you
don't have to agree or disagree look
what you don't have to be this good Josh
I'm speaking taeran if you don't mind so
what was gonna say was the reason why
only possible things cannot be in
existence is because you have the
absurdity of dependent things depending
of depending upon dependent things ad
infinitum so you have compound in the
dependency in other words there's no
necessary
for anything to come into existence in
particular so in other words my
postulation is as follows my postulation
is that there must be a necessary being
through which all other dependent things
all other contingent things depend on in
order for there to be any existence in
the first place now here's my question
to you if you say there must be a
necessary technology that's necessary it
must be but you have it so how's that
going to be and you also said you think
that's also going to be a world where
there are only possible things I'll tell
you why that's implying that there's
everywhere there are impossible things
no no absolutely so okay you've got
through categories right absolutely
right
you've got impossible things like a
squared circle which cannot be in
existence we agree with that right me
and you agree a squared circle cannot
exist in the real world then you have
things which are contingent things which
are possible things which could have
otherwise been differently or which if
you take out of creation the creation
doesn't collapse these things are
dependent things they're contingent
things all right then you have and this
is what my population is you must have a
necessary being that puts all other
contingent things into existence and
through which it can depend on otherwise
you have the absurdity of dependent
things depending upon dependent things
ad infinitum now what I'm saying is as
simple as this right from my perspective
I could not imagine it's not possible I
would say it's logically unfeasible from
a epistemological perspective for there
to be a world with only dependent things
can you explain how there could be a
world with only dependent things and
first of all that's that's answer I
don't see you sir
yeah even yeah even when we have
symbiosis there's an evolution to get
there
right right right so that so what I'm
saying is no problem so would you agree
with me that there's a necessary
existence that puts all other possible
things into existence
no why not there's no indication no no
there is no you know what the indication
of a is wait do you know what the
indication of that is let me show you
what the immigration alida pirate so say
for example let me put this in
mathematical terms say you have a series
you know gonna help you go there no you
know you don't know right you're sorry
you say you have a series and and in
that series you have possible things in
that series possible one possible to
possible call it dependent thing
contingent thing whatever you want to
call it yes let me explain to you I'm
using a cosmological example right which
is an example which makes reference to
the universe but putting it in a
mathematical term I'm not sick right
very good
oh no but that's good so I'm saying is
that for example Harun Aaron listen to
me what I'm saying is it's very simple
right if you have that number of false
premises then you're gonna get to a
false conclusion that's what I'm reading
so okay so premise 1 Impossibles or
let's say a postulation 1 impossible
things can't be in existence a squared
circle can't be in existence agreed to a
and great all right impossible means
impossible all right a possible thing
like for example this happen it's got NY
on it right New York right now this hat
could have had on it LA yes you could
have had on the LA right it could have
been a blue it could've been a green hat
now that so in other words this cap that
he's got on his head is a possible
contingent thing yeah I'm sure you're
aware of this this argument right ok I'm
sure right wondering if it's going to go
nothing now and yet it didn't have to
exist right now a necessary fact is two
plus two equals four agreed because that
fact two plus two equals four could not
be any other way
all right but we're not changing we're
not changing the axiom cuz it's the only
person with Nana we're not check we're
not changing we could go to gold or we
can go to and then that but for the sake
of argument we're saying two plus two
equals four unless we want to really
make this an absurd argument or go crazy
okay is two plus two equals four is a
necessary fact so in other words it's
eternally going to be two plus two is
always going to be four okay right so
unnecessary fact is something which
could not be any other way in the
context of existence why I'm saying is
that you have possible existences and
you must have a necessary existence
because because if you have only
possible existences which could be any
other way then it's conceivable that
this world would have been any other way
this universe could have been any other
way just within this galaxy alright so
there must exceed every other way is
probably out there perfect so y'all see
you're agreeing that this universe could
have been any other way
no I'm saying yeah right right
there's a gap between unnecessary being
and God so even are not for me I don't
think even if you establish for you
that's the thing no I'm not saying
Christianity I think theism and even if
you think about can we do one thing
outside to say well talking to an
atheist never say I'm saying just
because I just wanna climb that this
year yeah you can establish the
necessary existence of this big right
but that doesn't mean that there has to
be we haven't done that yet with him so
can we do that the properties of God can
have that's a separate discussion Josh
side-effect if you're trying to prove
God to an atheist or your deacon very
good question good argument for God's
existence and I don't think loggers
that's finebros so that's fine but you
understand now the point I'm making to
you is if you have a world of only
possible existences nothing like force
nothing the only thing you put in now
you can't have that we knew
can only have a world of possible okay
can't have no no no no juxtapose in the
word possible with impossible I agree
with you that's correct
Aaron we were yes yeah exactly right yes
yes right excellent
so that's a really good question so we
said two plus two equals four is a
necessary fact it will always be two
plus two equals four eternally right
necessary because it couldn't be any
other way it's not what's your name
what's your name
Julia it's by the way it's not
everything this is not what I call it
this is what live myths call it it's
what gold will calls it is what at least
I know cause it's what flour are before
everybody said it's cause it necessary
existence so I'm not calling it anything
I'm just bringing you back what's in the
literature regardless of the names you
program yeah anybody united great you
have to understand the argument to be
able to convey that or it doesn't matter
that some other people written a book on
it actually it's called Kalam
cosmological arguments you can you can
buy it if you want is actually a
best-seller now in the atheist of if
your section it's overtaking The God
Delusion so I think I have actually
understood yogi McKay has been
peer-reviewed as well you can check
that's not my friend that's not my fault
you're meant to but you're meant to be
an atheist specialist and you're right
right so if you don't understand the
argument you're one of the figures of
new figureheads of New Atheism if you
don't understand the argument then
there's only one thing I can do is I
could try and relay the argument but
it's not it's not my fault that you're
not understanding now let me say one
more time let me make it as easy as
possible right say say you have a phone
this is the phone okay yes okay let me
make this as simple as possible is it
dependent on something it's dependent on
charge I have to put the charger inside
yes
not the existence of yeah the
functioning we're just good excellent
thank you for that let's get any better
from here yeah it does but you have to
be patient because I'm losing that I
should have gone already Aaron if I was
listening to something you're saying I
was trying to get what you're saying
right we all will have to be patient
with your child for learning to take
place you had time then all right that
time there Aaron this phone has charged
in it okay if you put it requires a
charge I in order to be charged now say
for example I connect this phone to
another phone yes with a wire I put this
phone to another phone so what on a wire
right you've got this phone another
phone in a wire right and then you've
got that phone with a telephone in the
wire
so you've got three phones right you
have three phones if you have three
phones what eventually happens to the
functionality of the phone that the
charge will run out would you finish
just just you're just poisoning the
world well everyone can see what you're
doing and and you know it's looking
cheap it's looking I'm watching as
a Christian you should just know I'll
have the discussion later is emptiness
thought it's about what is it good all
wrong no no let me let me make it there
and then you clarify the point let me
let me feel Josh let me speak about let
me make the argument and then you can
judge I've seen just the middle of me
well whatever you finish what you
haven't you haven't let me finish I mean
if you don't let someone finish and then
you say it's not good then that's
actually disingenuine T alright so
you've got three phones say for example
of them got charged right so I connect
this phone to another phone and this
phone to another phone now what will
happen if I connect all three of them to
allow them all to charge using each
other's energies eventually they all run
out of charge we all agree and the
reason why is because they all dependent
they all depend the phone is depended
charge of the phone the analogy here is
the charge of the phone the charge of
the phone is dependent
yes now I'm saying is if you have a
world owner of limited what you call it
limited dependent things all of them
will depend upon another thing and if
this is in the context of existence you
would not have existence because you
have to have something which depends
upon nothing in order for everything
else to exist
does that make sense so in other words
an hour an hour example and the analogy
you have to have an infinite power
source so we were going back to what we
just said the necessary existence that
existence that yeah yeah yeah yeah now
what I'm saying is now I've shown is
that possible or contingent things by
definition are dependent a phone this
phone is dependent on another phone for
charge that phone on another phone for
charge if we connect them right now one
just let me finish if you have three of
them if you have files then if you have
ten of them then they're all going to be
dependent on each other now what's going
to eventually happen on the with the
phones they're going to run out of
charge what I'm saying to you is that
the functionality of the phone's charge
here is analogous to existence in my
analogy and also a lot perfect analogy
you could destroy the analogy if you
want but what I'm saying is that this is
my only thing that I can try and break
droid closer to you so if things which
are dependent depend upon dependent
things add in ad infinitum unless
there's an infinite power source
somewhere in the equation there will not
be any existence and what I'm saying is
that the infinite power source if you
like all the necessary existence that we
refer to is God and now we call it God
what it's not not an infinite power
source it can't be right it has to be
why because otherwise nothing else would
be in existence
yep go and Judy you understand this one
you get it so we get our energy from the
Sun yes yes good and excellent happy
input no it don't hold on this very good
example so we're in for example um well
an ecosystem right you got human beings
you got animals whatever you want all of
that is dependent upon the Sun yes the
Sun itself it's not infinite but the
front of the Sun itself is dependent
upon other things no other Suns are the
galaxies are independent it depends on
the laws of physics it's dependent upon
a range of factors helium if you don't
have helium you can have a son you have
to have different if you break down the
Sun we agree right so the Sun is
dependent are we agree yeah now is Julia
can we can we sticked sorry sorry before
before you continue less he understands
this or I just want him to fully
understand the argument he's he's
already nearly there what you said is
that the Sun is the it's not the Panther
or something else we've shown actually
it is right so the whole universe now
there's only two ways you can go no
problem is the universe dependent or
independent the way you're talking about
the Sun having to have fuel if I take
that yeah yeah then if the soldiers
depended on other things yes five didn't
it's perfect
so the excellent exit right right so the
same thing now so what we need to have
because that chain will continue going
dependent things can't depend upon
dependent things ad infinitum you have
to have something which is necessary
yeah of course what I'm saying is that
there is a Miss impossible it's
logically inconceivable that dependent
things can depend upon dependent things
ad infinitum what I'm saying is that or
not infinite to me that I'm out of here
they depend upon other things can you
prove to me that they don't you know one
trying to prove something to me the
burden I've set your so you've just made
a claim actually you said that you said
that particles don't depends on anything
can you prove that no I've said that for
your argument to hold I need to show
that the particles don't all right so
here's the thing what you and Aaron
couldn't deal with is this the new
atheist view but it's Paula the new
atheist movement is crumbling right in
front of me one by one every single one
of them cannot deal with this argument
because by the way I can't believe it
was like you know it really all in all
it took was just a little bit of
bringing out an argument and the whole
new atheist movement in front of my very
eyes standing up creature so what was
your argument of all you need to show
that fundamentals so you said jr. you
said right here right now it was under
camera I know I'm like I say I believe
about the case I can't I can't because
I'm telling you that before you aren't
even talking it showed that that were
case and fundamental particles depend on
some
okay they depend upon the laws of nature
no oh wait a minute no no the road II
mean they depend a little the laws of
physics which are which are presupposed
by the study of psyche need never know
can you tell me what the laws of physics
are there are many if you want to go and
see a book or I want you to tell me what
you think those are caramels your pusher
yes okay so you can be described in
different ways mine which is got his and
he's got a equals job actually give a
number zero point zero seven significant
physical physics when mathematics apply
to universal law
yes okay so when he says zero point zero
seven is a number n which is applied to
the universe is that well he looks out
for look at me for example right yes so
he says that that's the conversion of
helium into energy for example
I'm saying to you now but you know you
said that the particles are fundamental
particles don't depend on every anything
you said unless you want to retract that
statement which is what every atheist
does when they're in front of me now you
said that fundamental particles don't
depend on anything
now did you believe that fundamental
particles don't depend on anything thank
you for saying that because now what
you've shown is that you believe in the
existence of an independent being but
the only thing is no no hold on the only
thing is now no no no no problem but you
extend because before you were saying
there's no such thing as a necessary
thing you're saying now there's no hold
on Julie you're gonna retract your
statement because that's what every
atheist does in front of me
it's on camera you said you'd believe
you just started four minutes ago you
just said you believe that fundamental
particles are not dependent on anything
by definition what you're effectively
saying is you believe fundamental
particles are independent now obsolete
whenever name what I see what I mean
when I say fundamental algorithm I'm
just explaining what the standard model
says okay go ahead mentally yeah
according to quantum field theory energy
spikes by your belief Julie should have
come into their tribe to challenge me
because what you've done now seriously
you should really think about it before
you come inside to make claims well do
you need to you shouldn't have come here
because what you've done now is you've
given me exactly why I want it in the
beginning you said that I have to prove
that is necessary independent being now
you've just said you believe that
fundamental particles are not dependent
on your words exactly you believe you
said I believe fundamental particles are
not dependent on anything
now all I'm saying as a Muslim is that
my my understanding let me finish let me
finish you know your God yeah yo go to
the newer it is that then the only
difference between my god and your God
is size that's the only difference
yes no honestly yeah you need to
understand judo and atheist anymore in
front of me and use you said that and
also I want Julie Julie now you don't
think you give me exactly
particles are independent that's why she
said it not dependent on anything that's
the definition of Independence now if
you believe in an independent now let me
tell you something for aesthetic
perspective you have to understand this
wait a minute you said not dependent on
anything
how can someone how can something be not
depend I think the light dependent is
very misleading because it's like
fundamentally even inside the standard
bottle things tip like more
interdependent they depend on a
fundamental level and the thing is I
know that so there is some particles of
energy you're saying
[Laughter]
the